We're going to talk about how
we control access to resources.
These are protected resources.
Any program can make a request for
such a resource,
and we need to decide if the request
should be allowed to go ahead,
it should be granted,
or we have to deny it.
So we've been talking
about the importance
of the trusted computing base.
In fact, when someone is asking for
a resource, they are generating
a reference for that.
They have to reference the resource they
are interested in or they want to use,
so the trusted computing base has
to act as a reference monitor.
No request for resource should go
without the trusted computing base being
involved in checking that request.
Obviously, it'll have to see
the source of the request is,
what the target, or
what resource is being requested.
And then we're going to discuss how
do we decide if it should be granted.
As a quick example, let's say John is
a student in a class and there's a file
that has the grades of all the students
who are enrolled in that class.
John, obviously,
can make a request to read that file.
Not only he wants to see his own grade,
maybe he's curious about how other
people did on a certain test or an exam.
So John could make
a request to read a file.
In this case,
we not only have to monitor the request
that is going to come from John, but
our access control that we going to do
should decide that John should not be
able to see other people's grades.
So, in this case,
the result may be denying the request.
But the idea here is that references
have to be monitored, and
then we have to make some sort of
a decision when a request comes,
whether it should go ahead or
it should be denied.
So we talked about authentication.
Authentication basically tells
us when an application or
a process makes a request, on whose
behalf that request is being made.
So the example that we're just
talking about, it's a process
that John launched, then it is
going to have John's User ID or UID.
And authentication is how we know that
this particular UID should be associated
with the process.
Authentication tells
us about the source.
Authorization, or access control,
which is the topic for this lesson,
is going to answer the question
knowing the source of a request,
authentication is going to tell us that.
Once we know the source of a request,
in this case a User ID, and
the target of the request, which is a
file, and what they want to do with this
resource is read this file,
should we let them do it or not?
So access control is similar
to what we have in real world.
You want to access something, and
somebody has to decide, in this case,
the TCB, or the reference monitor that
is implemented by the TCB, whether that
access is one that should be allowed to
proceed or go forward, or it should not.
So let's quickly talk about how
do we actually decide this.
Resources that we have in the system,
for
example, files are created by
certain users or subjects.
You can, perhaps,
think if Alice is creating a file,
maybe she has the ability to decide who
should be able to access it or not.
The intention here being,
it's her file, she chooses to
decide who to share it with.
So in many systems, actually, the idea
of an owner of a resource is defined.
This is the subject who
creates the resource, and
it is at the discretion of the owner
how that resource can be shared.
There are other kind of systems
where this may not be the case and
we're going to talk about that.
For example, if you work for a company,
the company may not allow you to
decide how you can share certain
sensitive data about that company.